Hi - Oh, das war ein doofer Klatscher!
Hi zusammen!
Wir machen heute ein ganz gechillte Runde Plätzchen backen!
Ich hab wieder ein geniales Rezept im Gepäck, und zwar 1 Teig, 3 Plätzchen!
3 richtig unterschiedliche Plätzchen!
Man sieht nicht auf den ersten Blick, dass das alles aus einem Teig entstanden ist.
So, und jetzt fange ich auch direkt an, ihr kennt das Spielchen:
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben findet ihr unten in der Videobeschreibung schön aufgelistet.
Ich starte jetzt mit meiner weichen Butter.
Bitte 1h vorher aus dem Kühlschrank nehmen, die sollte richtig schön zimmerwarm sein.
Die könnt ihr auch am Vorabend rausnehmen.
So, die gebe ich jetzt in die Küchenmaschine.
Falls ihr ein  Handrührgerät habt, dann benutzt das gerne.
So, da gebe ich die Butter rein, außerdem Zucker,
Vanilleextrakt - Vanille gibt einfach jedem Gebäck nochmal 'ne schöne Note.
So! Und gleich auch noch 'ne schöne Prise Salz, denn Hamza..?
[Kiki] Die hebt..?
[Hamza] Achso! *lacht* Die hebt den Geschmack!
Die hebt nochmal den süßen Geschmack. Hamza kann den Spruch nicht mehr hören aber es ist so!
[Kiki] Et is so!
[Hamza] Sorry, ich war grad am Träumen!
[Hamza] Aber sowas von!
[Kiki] Ja, du darfst nicht träumen!
[Kiki] Ah!
[Hamza] Ja, aber du!
[Kiki] *lacht*
So, Salz. Und jetzt 4min lang schön mixen, mittlere Geschwindigkeit.
Danach rühre ich ganz kurz die Eier ein und dann kommen auch schon die trockenen Zutaten.
[Hamza] Weißt du was, Kiki? Ich glaub man merkt einfach, dass du Spaß am Backen hast!
[Kiki] Ich hab Spaß an der Freud, das stimmt!
[Hamza] Ja, es ist so!
Mehl und Backkakao sieben wir dann hinzu.
Bitte, bitte unbedingt sogar sieben damit keine Klümpchen und Mehlnester da drin entstehen.
Und Backkakao, bitte nicht den Trinkkakao nehmen.
Also nicht den Kaba, Nesquik und wie sie alle heißen -
[Hamza] Heey, mach keine Werbung!
[Kiki] Waaas?
Das muss wirklich stark entölter Kakao sein, sonst klappt das Ganze nicht.
So und danach hab ich noch ein bisschen Milch dazugegeben.
Ich schreibe euch natürlich alles ganz genau in die Videobeschreibung.
Und jetzt kommt's: Jetzt nehmen wir uns 2/3 weg.
Also erstmal ein Drittel, dann noch ein Drittel.
Packe ich mir hier in meine Frischhaltedosen und gebe das für 1h in den Kühlschrank.
Und was ich mit dem anderen Drittel mache, das zeige ich euch
und das sind dann schon unseren ersten Kekse.
So, die zwei Tei-
So, zwei -
Die zwei Frischhaltedosen -
*beide lachen*
Okay. Soll ich mal sagen, was du hinter der Kamera machst? Lieber nicht!
Also!
Die 2 Frischhaltedosen sind jetzt im Kühlschrank.
Ich mache jetzt wie gesagt hiermit weiter.
Denn zum anderen Drittel kommt jetzt noch ein Schluck Milch, kurz einrühren
und dann gebe ich das in meinen Spritzbeutel mit Sterntülle.
So, bei meinem Schoko-Spritzgebäck hab ich jetzt 3 sehr, sehr wichtige Tipps für euch.
Tipp Nr. 1: Fügt so viel Milch hinzu, bis der Teig nicht ganz weich wird aber geschmeidig.
Und der darf auch nicht zu hart sein, sonst könnt ihr den nicht aufspritzen.
Und es kommt auch wirklich immer auf das Volumen der Eier an.
Ich schreibe euch wie gesagt aber auch noch 'ne Angabe unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Tipp Nr. 2: Gebt euch immer nur ein bisschen was - das hab ich nämlich gerade auch nochmal gemacht -
nur ein bisschen was in den Spritzbeutel damit ihr nicht so viel Druck ausüben müsst
und das Ganze viel einfach aufspritzen könnt.
Tipp Numero 3: Nehmt euch ein Messer, um dann den Abschluss zu finden und den Rest einfach so quasi wegzuschaben.
So, und jetzt kommt das bei mir in den Backofen.
190° C Ober- und Unterhitze. Der Backofen muss immer vorgeheizt sein, ganz, ganz wichtig!
Und da dauern die weil die jetzt auch relativ hoch sind so ungefähr 10-12min.
Die dürfen nicht zu trocken werden, also ich mag's lieber, wenn sie kürzer backen.
Und dann tunke ich später noch die Spitzen in geschmolzene Kuvertüre.
[Kiki] Ich mach jetzt noch 'n bisschen Mandelkrokant oben drauf.
[Hamza] Ja, das sieht toll aus!
[Kiki] Ja, das sieht richtig festlich aus!
[Hamza] Also jetzt sieht das aus wie richtig teure Kekse. Also wirklich, so richtig teure!
[Kiki] Weißt du was Hamza? Weil die selbstgemacht sind, sind die auch sehr teuer.
[Hamza] Ja!
[Kiki] Da steckt Handarbeit..
[Hamza] Da steckt Liebe drin!
[Kiki] Und Liebe, genau!
Für die Haselnuss-Schoko-Plätzchen rollt ihr euch den Teig ganz dünn auf der bemehlten Arbeitsfläche aus
und stecht euch Kreise aus. Meine sind sehr klein, ca. 3cm und relativ flach.
Und dann gebe ich sie auf ein mit Backpapier ausgelegtes Backblech,
gebe sie in den vorgeheizten Backofen bei 190° C Ober- und Unterhitze.
Und da brauchen sie aufgrund dessen, dass sie wirklich nur ganz dünn sind, ungefähr 6min.
Danach lasse ich sie vollständig auskühlen
und zeige euch jetzt, was ich - also das werden so Doppeldecker -
und zeige euch jetzt, was ich als Zwischenschicht nehme.
Und da habe ich hier Mascarpone und das Highlight in diesem Video:
meine Haselnusscreme!
Und - ah, die riecht traumhaft!
Und das machen wir jetzt folgendermaßen einfach:
Ich hab euch ja gesagt meine Haselnusscreme ist zwar auch ein Brotaufstrich, aber man kann sie auch als Creme verwenden,
daher.. schaut euch das mal an! Das hier -
[Hamza] Das nennt man Stolz!
Das ist - wir sind unfassbar stolz. Es ist wie ein Baby, das geboren ist!
Aber ihr kennt ja - wenn ihr uns auf Instagram folgt, kennt ihr auch die ganze Geschichte dazu.
Und demnächst kommt auch ein Video online.
Und da- schaut mal, wie das gleich fließen wird!
Und das gebe ich einfach mit zur Mascarpone. Oh, ein Traum!
Und dann einfach nur kurz verrühren.
Mascarpone dürft ihr nie zu lange verrühren, sonst wird sie nämlich flüssig.
Und dann fülle ich mir das in eine Spritzbeutel mit Lochtülle
und dann wird das ganz einfach befüllt.
So, jetzt kommt die dritte Variante und dafür müsst ihr den Teig nicht ausrollen.
[Hamza] Jetzt wird's crazy!
[Kiki] Jetzt wird's crazy, würd ich jetzt auch mal so sagen!
Der Teig ist natürlich durch den Kühlschrank ein bisschen fester geworden und genauso brauchen wir den auch.
Deshalb hab ich das jetzt wirklich auch als drittes genommen weil wir nehmen uns jetzt so..
[Hamza] Wo ist eigentlich deine Schürze?
[Kiki] Heute hab ich mir gedacht: Keine Schürze sondern so richtig gemütlichen Winterpulli an,
[Kiki] Haare zusammenbinden und dann drauf los backen!
[Hamza] Du meinst das auch noch voll ernst!
[Kiki] Ja Leute, macht's wie ich! Zieht euch den gemütlichsten Pulli an, den ihr finden könnt
[Kiki] und dann backt Kekse!
[Hamza] Ok, ok , komm mach weiter! Los, los!
Also, ihr nehmt euch jetzt so ein Stück.. was ist das? So..
[Hamza] Stück Keks!
[Kiki] Neiiin!
[Hamza] Teig! Kugel!
[Kiki] *lacht* Nein!
[Kiki] Nein! Nicht golfballgroß, nicht walnussgroß, sondern?
[Hamza] Tischtennisballgroß!
[Kiki] Das ist doch nicht tischtennisballgroß!
[Hamza] Keine Ahnung!
[Kiki] Auf jeden Fall so, wie ihr's hier seht.
[Kiki] Schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare, mit welcher Größe man das vergleichen kann! *lacht*
[Hamza] Murmelgroß, Murmel!
[Kiki] Murmelgroß, ganz toll!
[Kiki] So, und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einen Schokobon. Ja, ihr habt richtig gehört -
[Hamza] Sag doch einfach schokobongroß!
[Kiki] Ein schokobongroßer - oh mein Gott! Wir kommen echt mega verwirrt rüber in diesem Video!
[Kiki] Alle, die jetzt neu einschalten, denken: "Was sind das für verrückte Menschen?!"
[Hamza] Wir haben noch nicht gegessen! *lacht*
Wir haben noch kein Mittag gehabt aber es liegt hier schon bereit!
Also, wir umhüllen jetzt das Schokobon mit dem Teig -
[Hamza] Geh mal weiter runter!
[Kiki] Oh tschuldigung! Mit dem Teig. Moment, ich mach nochmal so den hier..
[Kiki] So und jetzt einfach aufs Backblech tun!
So, im vorgeheizten Backofen bei 190° C brauchen die nur 10min,
die müssen wirklich nur außen schön gar werden aber noch nicht zu trocken,
sondern richtig schön zart und weich.
Und innen ist ja der Schokobon, der muss ja nicht irgendwie durchgebacken werden oder so.
Und dann macht ihr folgendes: Nehmt auch Puderzucker, am besten hier mit so 'nem Sieb
und dann einfach direkt wenn's ausm Ofen kommt draufgeben
und dann bildet das so 'ne richtig schöne Haut.
Der Puderzucker schmilzt an der Oberfläche.
[Kiki] Richtig lecker! Das sieht aus wie so..
[Hamza] Sieht richtig winterlich aus!
[Kiki] Ja, finde ich auch!
Und jetzt guckt euch mal an, wie das im Inneren aussieht!
[Hamza] Boah, sieht richtig lecker aus!
[Kiki] Hammer, ne?
Ja, find ich auch! Und wie sagt man immer so schön?
Schokobons, mit einem Haps sind sie im Mund!
[Kiki] Mh, heiß!
[Hamza] Das war ein halber Schokobon!
[Kiki] Heiß!
[Hamza] Heiß?
[Kiki] Boah, aber lecker!
[Hamza] Okay, wir essen die morgen einfach!
[Kiki] Mhm, mhm..okay. Oh..
[Hamza] Kiki nein!
[Kiki] Ich will essen!
[Hamza] Nein morgen, hör auf!
[Kiki] Ein..
[Hamza] Nein, das ist voll unfair! Ich will auch!
[Kiki] Oah!
[Kiki] Boah, wie weich!
[Hamza] Ja >:(
[Kiki] Die erinnern mich an Macarons. Natürlich Welten davon entfernt aber so ein bisschen.. so ein bisschen, ne?
[Kiki] So Schoko Macarons!
[Hamza] Sehen ein bisschen aus wie Oreos und Macarons.
[Kiki] Ja, so ne Kreuzung. Hammer lecker!
[Kiki] Leute ich muss euch jetzt verabschieden, ich mach mir noch 'nen Kaffee und ein paar nehm ich hier weg..
[Hamza] Wieso Kaffee? Vorher ess ich, ich hab Hunger!
[Hamza] Wir haben nichts gegessen!
[Kiki] Ich könnt echt nur Süßes essen den ganzen Tag!
Ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Spaß beim Nachbacken!
Hinterlasst diesem Video unbedingt ein Däumchen nach oben wenn es euch gefallen hat
und meinem Kanal natürlich ein kostenloses Abo! Ich hab noch dieses.. - Kennst du das ? - im Mund!
[Hamza] Sorry Leute, dass ich in diesem Video bisschen viel geredet hab aber ich hab das Bedürfnis zu reden.
[Kiki] Hamza dafür musst du dich nicht entschuldigen! Hamza ist das "Kitchen" bei "Kikis", wisst ihr doch!
[Hamza] Ja aber ich glaub da sind manche nicht so..
[Kiki] M-mh! Das will nicht nicht hören!
[Hamza] M-mh!
[Kiki] Das will nicht nicht hören!
[Hamza] Okay.
Also jetzt nochmal ganz viel Freude beim Nachbacken
und ich freue mich, von euch in den Kommentaren zu lesen und natürlich freue ich mich auf eure Fotos.
[Kiki] Letztes Mal habt ihr mir so viele Fotos geschickt über Instagram, TikTok sogar, richtig geil!
[Hamza] Ich find die sehen auch heftig aus die Kekse!
[Kiki] Find ich auch!
[Hamza] Ich find die von der Optik her nochmal 'nen Ticken schöner. Ich weiß nicht, wie die geschmacklich sind..
[Kiki] 'Nen Ticken schöner als beim letzten Mal?
[Hamza] Ja klar!
[Kiki] Joa! Letztes Mal war's so ein richtig typisches Plätzchenteller und das ist so die coole Variante.
[Hamza] Ja find ich auch!
Also ich verabschiede mich jetzt von euch wünsch euch noch 'nen wunderschönen Tag!
Bis bald, eure Kiki! Und der Hamza hinter der Kamera, haha!
[Hamza] *lacht* Was war das denn? Deine Lache!